about a hand for the 30-plus players
coaches and management coming back to st
louis tonight to celebrate the 2011
world series championship
and now for our ceremonial first pitch
throwing out the ceremonial first pitch
on behalf of the 2011 team your world
series mvp david freeze and cardinals
hall of famer chris carpenter
catching the pitches will be third
baseman nolan aronado and pitcher jack
flaherty
and adam wainwright the right guy to be
pitching
so bueno is on the mound tonight part of
that 06 reunion the 11 reunion the
problem is he's still in uniform still
throws uh just a tad below 90 miles an
hour the curveball obviously the big
pitch for wainwright he's going to use
it a lot 34 percent of the time
diving stop tommy edmond he robs
croninworth what a play joey's left
tommy edmond oh man
cardinals defense
has been spectacular the last well
all year it's been spectacular but
especially the last 10 days and tommy
edmonds been a part of that
back to bueno no underhand to first
the padres strand a runner and the
cardinals coming up in the home half of
the first
time to turn it around for the 35 year
old veteran making his 28th start that's
you darvish talked about his outings
ever since the all-star break last time
out a rough one
eight earned runs gave up four home runs
that was in four innings against the
giants
fernando tatis jr from shortstop fires
across good job receiving by cronenworth
and a one two three first for darvish
now they go back to their normal
positions as that wayne wright winds and
fires in the old two is a ground ball up
the middle a great play by
tommy edmonds
wow you talking about defense this is
something else in this game he's putting
on a show he is he's putting on a gold
glove show and remember he he replaced
the gold glover yeah he now plays in
milwaukee but those are colton wong-like
plays those guys have been great with
the town halls that we had during covet
for fans
a lot of fun to
have those guys back in town
then final out
i got good news for you they didn't
score the first
they got three last night and went on to
win molina punches out
and quickly two down here in the bottom
of the second inning for you darvish his
first strike out of the night
swing a big chalet too by the way terry
pendleton
golfed but that one will stay in the
yard tatis the only guy in the left side
makes the play six up six down for
darvish that a nine pitch in it
[Music]
machado last night went one for eight
croninworth
pops it up and caught by nolan arenado
coming up
and there's no score
nicely stopped by manny and sosa is out
corona worth good job uh keeping the
foot on the bag at first base at least
according to corey blazer who's the
umpire over there yeah i think he's on
the bag
what do you think jess
he's out
darvish matching his heroes here today
though and nine up nine down to start
the afternoon
for you
made the last out of the last inning so
they give him time to get back out there
and settle in first pitch curveball over
the head of arnotto and into left field
for a base head manny is two for two
down in the zone and somehow it finds
his way out into right field for a base
hit man he's on his way to third base he
gets there without a play
back to back singles to start the fourth
inning against wainwright and the padres
are in business with runners on the
corners and nobody out tommy pham big
spot here as the padres look to break
through in the run column
fastball that time and lined into center
field for a base here padres will take
the lead three straight hits to start
the fourth inning and fraser makes it
all the way to third base
one to nothing san diego
and the o2 he got him on the inside
corner and the first strikeout for
wainwright
and there's two away
[Applause]
that is up the middle and into center
field for a base hit frazier will come
in to score fam's on his way to third
and the fourth hit of the inning for the
padres produces their second run
two to nothing
the one-two pitch
garbage puts it in play backhanded by
sosa force play at second
and the padres here in the top of the
fourth they strike first and it's two
nothing san diego caratini initially set
up inside and now he backs away and he
got the call again strike three and
o'neil can't believe it
darvish has gone out there three times
now to collect a strikeout but that one
might have been even more off the plate
than the previous two here's the eighth
pitch of the at-bat and it is at the top
of the zone strike three call
back-to-back punch outs for darvish and
now two on and two out now molina all
that's standing between darvish and a
clean getaway edmond finally goes from
second in the pitch hit in the air
out to left field should be playable for
tommy pham and he makes the catch you
darvish gets out of his sticky situation
to tease cronenworth and machado
he struck him out he gets to tease
and adam wainwright is one strikeout shy
of 2000.
jace tingler i'm not sure arguing and
you can't argue balls and strikes i
wonder if he's already been tossed
that's gonna be it for him he's out
couple of starts last season for darvish
against st louis got the win both times
got him
first time tonight darvish gets a
swinging strikeout he's got half a dozen
k's
and two outs with nobody on here in the
bottom of the fifth inning
got him
back-to-back case for darvish he's got
seven and another one two three inning
going to the sixth in saint louis
the 2-1 pitch
and carpenter drives it
out to deep right center
one hopper off the wall matt carpenter
on his way to second base standing up
pinch hit double
matt carpenter
darvish has picked these guys apart all
night long
went out to that spot gets the call
again darvish all of a sudden with eight
strikeouts and five in the third one and
two to o'neal
[Applause]
got him
keep on going back nine strikeouts for
darvish
reads four and grounded up the middle
fernando's got it
and the side is retired for the second
time in three innings darvish works out
of a jam
and a fly ball into right field going
back carl senate's off the wall plays it
perfectly here's his throw in his second
he got him oh what a throw on a fly
dylan carlson with a strike to second
and he places perfectly and i love the
way he times up his throat too he makes
sure he's got a good grip and he throws
a strike right on the money
that's on the ground up the middle
fernando's got it and the fifth one two
three inning of the night for you
darvish he gets through the seventh on
just nine pitches
[Applause]
fly ball plenty deep to score harrison
bader
this will cut the lead to 2-1
the tying run is aboard potential
go-ahead run will come to the plate the
2-2
o'nail with
[Applause]
tyler o'neal
the redbirds
on top
karen the egg what a great moment
the crowd has been waiting for this
danny off the bench eric hosmer
and the final hope for san diego the 0-2
pitch
he struck him out
seven straight
nine
above 500.
you